[Musik]
los angeles
stockheim mit egal wo sie sind
[Musik]
da
lila
[Musik]
mathe abi dhabi
ergolding
[Musik]
heute ist der große tag in hollywood und
der oscar in der kategorie bester
chauffeur geht an randy
heute ist die oscar-verleihung und ich
muss meinen kunden abholen ist der
präsident der disney studios
zwei ihrer filme nehmen am wettbewerb in
der kategorie animation teil dieses jahr
bin ich zum siebzehnten mal bei der
verleihung dabei ich habe schon für
große schauspieler gearbeitet wie
bradley cooper und ist leider darf man
nicht filmen wenn mein kunde im wagen
sitzt auch nicht wenn wir beim roten
teppich ankommt wegen der sicherheit
deshalb werden sie diesen moment leider
nicht sehen können
[Musik]
nein erst film geht wirklich nicht
die vernissage tech open ausstellung
rückt näher
leser muss die liebenden sind auf der
zielgeraden
das projekt ist noch nicht ganz fertig
das ist etwas stressig es gibt viele
collagen viele gemälde viele
entscheidungen müssen getroffen
deshalb muss ich hier sein und mich
abschotten damit alles klappt sonst
werde ich nicht fertig
[Musik]
vor 15 jahren habe ich eine serie
gemacht mit dem corsa aus pasolinis film
die 120 tage von sodom ich bin wieder
auf dieses bild gestoßen als ich in das
neue atelier eingezogen bin da dachte
ich plötzlich dass ich etwas damit
machen könnte dass ich es fluchtraum
nennen könnte und dass ich es mit der
idee der lebenden oder mit der
gegensätzlichkeit der lebenden verbinden
könnte
ich musste ideen noch etwas köcheln
lassen die richtigen entscheidungen
fällen ich darf nicht zu viele fehler
machen
das bedeutet dass der nächste schritt
erst dann kommt wenn du sicher bist du
musst dir einfach die zeit geben damit
du dich konzentrieren kannst eintauscht
und abtaucht und untertauchen und ganz
durchtränkt
[Musik]
nein
die decke gemacht ja alles hängt
ich habe es gar nicht gesehen noch ein
letzter ab das geht wieder unglaublich
ein abdruck ist viel größer ist meine
das ist der verkaufspreis ich brauche
hier deine initialen
du musst hier unterschreiben chance wir
bleiben bis ende april
wir haben vereinbart dass wir das haus
noch einen monat bis zu unserem wegzug
mieten können gelesen genehmigt und
unterschrieben
pascual und daraus ist nun offiziell
verkauft muss ich alle meine ex frauen
angeben nein nur die aktuelle news wenn
du willst kannst du die rückseite
benutzen ich wahrscheinlich zwei sollten
ich glaube sich jetzt ziemlich fertig
momente wenn das datum schauen wir mal
ob man mit natürlich noch viel parker
finanz - mit luke wird das denn gar mit
dem gau die ponys und da ist das sich
nicht so einfach da leider mit es ist
gar nicht so einfach in kalifornien
seine steuern loszuwerden
das schließt das grundbuch machen habe
ich gehört
amerika ich glaube es muss das postkonto
gemacht will ich sie haben 1 prozent
jeden trick amerika und witz mit der
abmachung gesellschaft schon gar nicht
mit der haut schweizer banken noch eine
letzte sache wollt ihr einen scheck oder
eine gutschrift von konto zu konto
ich denke einen scheck ist besser ich
will nicht dass das geld hier auf ein
amerikanisches konto geht und dass dann
1000 komplikationen gibt
du musst das geld auf eine bank
überweisen die ein abkommen mit einer
schweizer bank
danke für die formulare alles in ordnung
ist dass jetzt alles sind wir fertig
550.000 aber 40.000 werden abgezogen
dann bleiben uns noch exakt 510.000 134
dollar und 84 cent gewöhnte sich hp
schweiz könig mit ich weiß es nicht
ein gebäude das denn zumeist sich aber
los angeles will die nummer findet
schöne kasimir schön gefunden
[Musik]
die größten studios haben sich in
burbank angesiedelt ganz in der nähe von
hollywood im zentrum der welthauptstadt
des films gestaltet regie das dekor neu
[Musik]
das ist der raum für die büros
ja ist einfach ein klinikum ist ob sie
da im prinzip der ruhm die tabelle
konzept machen im café shop in shop sie
in alex regierung auch ist kein problem
denn im rat pharma und dann hat sich das
progressive verändert natürlich bei
denen die meetings gegangen und hat
einfach realisiert dass gegen sie extrem
langsam anderen ich habe nur angst wegen
der kosten für die treppe das wird sehr
teuer
hier muss alles weg der boden die wände
dann wird alles erhöht die decke höher
so hoch wie möglich
irgendwie chance über und denn genau und
der schnitt jetzt hinterfragen was die
musiker das mache den job
meine mutter kommt vor
und da muss einfach mit und flexibel
sie leitet das projekt für einen
befreundeten investor wie durch zufall
sprechen sie dieselbe sprache ist er nun
bahnhofsgebäude inhalt die fabrik rom
beauftragt sind viele sache wo womit
weiß machte waren die weg und zwar für
immer mehr improvisieren
die größen nicht ausgerichtet so dass es
zufällig aussieht und da ist mir doch
sehr hin dieses schweizers mir ist noch
improvisieren und sachen work work man
mache da und den machen muss und von dem
her ist so gewaltig als machtmittel
schweizer schaffe ich habe ihm gesagt
wenn du wenn du was ich den job
übernehmen
der juni-kontrakt will im endeffekt weiß
sie dass sie mit einer dass herr bringen
so dass diese tür muss wirklich
außergewöhnlich werden wenn du sie
öffnet dann ja damals auch größtes
vertrauen darauf dass mögliche zwanziger
keinen ist es einfach da und da sind
[Musik]
der dichte stadtverkehr wird florian
bald verschlucken
ich bin auf dem weg zu meiner ersten
fahrstunde in den staaten das erste mal
mit automatik handschaltung kenne ich
schon von fahrstunden in der schweiz
ich weiß nicht ob das gut geht ich weiß
nicht mehr wo wir uns verabredet haben
[Musik]
hallo
in welchem parkett village parking
richtig ich habe keinen fahrausweis aber
ich bin schon 10 20 stunden gefahren mit
handschaltung
ok dann kannst du die
straßenverkehrsregeln ich habe keinen
einzigen fehler gemacht dann im lärm
weiter
das ist wichtig wenn du fährst nicht nur
für die prüfung um links abzubiegen
nein mit derselben hand und jetzt der
rückspiegel
ich hoffe die schranke geht auf
wie es niemand und war auch nicht es ist
so viel besser mit automatik und du
fährst du musst zuerst anhalten nichts
zeigt an dass wir hier nicht rechts
abbiegen dürfen
das sind kinder empfangen ist das frei
das sind fußgänger als sie am parkplatz
losfahren wollten war ich total
gestresst
ich dachte oh là là ich bin ja seit
sechs monaten oder sogar seit einem jahr
nicht mehr gefahren
aber jetzt geht es ganz gut außerdem ist
ja der fahrlehrer neben mir ich traue
mir das zu
kein gegenverkehr keine fußgänger
bekannt waren hatten die wegen der
geburt schon möglich
es gibt nicht viele kreuzungen in der
schweiz in die mitte fahren um links
abzubiegen
das habe ich noch nie gemacht
sie stoppen ja
sie braucht noch viel übungen bis sie
sich richtig wohl fühlt dann ist es da
die sie muss noch die verkehrsregeln
lernen neulenker lernen auf das handbuch
hilfe die prüfung und danach werfen sie
es weg los angeles ist ein schmelztiegel
aus verschiedenen fahrstil
es kommen viele leute her und die fahren
dann mit den ausweisen aus ihrer heimat
sie studieren nicht mal die
kalifornischen verkehrsregeln
das tempo ist da jemand wenn du hier
fahren lernst kannst du überall fahren
[Musik]
du bist zu weit weg das ist dann maximal
zulässige abstand etwas zurück
[Musik]
perfekt gut gemacht ich hätte gern einen
fahrausweis aber ich sehe mich nicht so
recht mit einem eigenen auto ich werde
wohl immer etwas angst haben und möchte
einfach nur den ausweis um einen zu
haben ich sehe mich eher unterwegs mit
freunden die einen wagen haben und
fahren und ich bin auf dem beifahrersitz
[Musik]
hinter den kulissen erhaschen hunderte
chauffeure einen hauch von hollywood
glamour ich habe gerade meinen kunden
auf dem roten teppich abgesetzt jetzt
warten wir hier bis die feier vorbei ist
und mein kunde anruft damit ich ihn
abholen kann
dann treffe ich mich mit meinen kollegen
und wir gehen zusammen an den ort wo
essen und getränke für uns vorbereitet
sind
da gibt es auch riesen bildschirme auf
denen man die feier live verfolgen kann
bis zu 23 uhr hier bleiben und dann geht
es zu den feiern die in der stadt
organisiert sind
[Musik]
dieses jahr habe ich für s dressuren
gearbeitet mit bradley cooper und lady
gaga es gefällt mir die verleihung zu
sehen und später meinen kunden die
gewonnen haben gratulieren zu können
ich als bodyguard gearbeitet habe war
ich zehn jahre lang beim film
es macht mir spaß die preisverleihung zu
sehen nicht alle aber die oscars immer
weil es der wichtigste abend in
hollywood ist als schauspieler war habe
ich immer davon geträumt einmal einen
oscar zu bekommen
manchmal denke ich dass ich als
schweizer schauspieler einen hätte
gewinnen können für eine große rolle
hätte spielen können
es bleibt ein traum so ist das halt
[Musik]
es ist ein wenig stressig aber mit der
ausstellung bin ich sehr zufrieden
heute abend wird gefeiert da bin ich
dann locker
das wird lustig es ist gut die arbeit
liegt jetzt in den händen der galeristin
[Musik]
los angeles ist zum neuen el dorado
zeitgenössische kunst geworden
freiheit und ein volles portemonnaie
zwei konzepte die harmonien
leser mehrheiten auf dieser welle
ich finde es stark dass frauen einen
raum bekommen um ihre arbeiten zu zeigen
[Musik]
das ist typisch erlebt dass du zufällig
an eine vernissage gehen kannst
das ist sehr schön und positiv
[Musik]
dieses projekt hört nicht in dem moment
auf in dem die werke ausgestellt werden
das ist der beginn des abenteuers
[Musik]
der große unterschied zwischen europa
und erlebt das ist interessant
aber wir sind jetzt mehr verbunden als
bisher
und wir sind glücklich dabei zu sein
[Musik]
ein raum für frauen als künstlerinnen
und mütter haben die vier freundinnen
den grundstein gelegt
[Musik]
reimann wir picken orangen das orangen
ernten ist bald vorbei die kann warten
das apfel pflücken steht bald bevor ich
dass ich hässlich und die das zähne im
kiefer und tanja flair oranges auftrag
für das frisch bleiben und themen
separat gemacht werde das sehr
geschwächten zeigt das sektfrühstück mit
soviel kippte - rückhalt gewidmetes
dribblings immer besser
zurück in der schweiz wehrt dora vom
wissen ihre schwester profitieren können
sie werden alle zusammen in ihrem haus
in macon wohnen in der nähe von luzern
mit der berge es ist jetzt offiziell das
musst du auf dich nur einmal koch hat
werden und nicht zweimal
das wird und glaubten zu mikrokrediten
morgen wieder na klar
[Musik]
meine schwester ist ja welt als ich und
sich immer mini kurs 53 sie immer
bewundert
ganz nah an drei werktagen grad sie hat
und henker und mini bezirk sind
eigentlich immer hinter meiner karriere
stand ich mit dem sie noch hinzu
[Musik]
ich spiele richtig du nicht obwohl ich
spiele allein
muss man den swing im blut haben beim
golfen wie im alltäglichen leben braucht
man energie und muss seine ziele
punktgenau an bayern
in der stadt des films und auf dem green
muss man sich beweisen und immer wieder
von vorn beginnen
manchmal glück deine party manchmal
verliert man alles
[Musik]
oder man bettelt um koks und eine
schnelle nummern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
1992 wurde meine mannschaft für eine
kinoproduktion engagiert bei einem film
für den sie american football spieler
für bestimmte szenen suchten sie wollten
leute die berufsspieler darstellten
daher kommt meine leidenschaft fürs
klima ich habe mir vorgestellt später
schauspieler und stuntmen zu werden
dann habe ich schritt für schritt meine
film karriere aufgebaut die zehn jahre
lang gedauert hat dass da bin ich mit
einer schauspielerin und model
ich habe ihren bodyguard gespielt ich
habe auch viele das bin ich
[Musik]
da hatte ich nur haare heute habe ich
keine mehr ist auch schon ziemlich lange
her
2001 nach den terroranschlägen vom 11
september ging plötzlich alles langsamer
sie wollten keine produktionen mehr
lancieren aus angst vor anschlägen
im dezember hatte ich dann finanzielle
schwierigkeiten weil ich nicht so viel
gearbeitet hatte ich habe in einigen
größeren filmen mitgespielt aber ich
hatte nie dialoge zu sprechen
meine figuren waren meist der bodyguard
der große harte typ aber ich bin schon
zufrieden mit dem was ich gemacht habe
[Musik]
im santa barbara county liegt eine
wahrhaft schweizerische börse des
friedens little wahlen statt
eine hommage an den kanton st gallen die
wahlheimat des architekten
das ist eigentlich ganz gut ist für mich
auch nicht schweizer erinnere
verschiedene schweizer anders ist jetzt
ein ja noch von früher gern gemacht wann
das buch einfach schön dass nicht immer
der stadt wohnen und obwohl im raum
strahlender nichts nütze die stadt ich
habe es einfach nicht
rosi und susann haben ihrem freund mein
rat der sich um das anwesen kümmert
einen teil des grundstücks abgekauft
haben in der stadt und eines tages hat
tusk aufgeholt hat und die strecken in
europa noch nicht berücksichtigt hand
mit der lokomotive emma kauf ich mache
mir vorstelle
[Gelächter]
ich war sieben gänge auf uns geschaut
dass die rechte und das ist der
wohnwagen über die reine schlafen
das ist schlafen und im haus aber auch
ein thema wie geht stimmigen zwar schon
wieder im bus schlafen das ist ein
totaler break vom normalen leben los
angeles dahinter haben aprikosenbäume
muscat bleu sind und die man jetzt
kontrollieren wasserleitungssystem
funktioniert und dann darüber die
zuschneiden und ja und dann ist das
rating für ihr großes können befreien
[Musik]
severin profitiert von allem was ihm
sein onkel roche mit seinem breiten
wissen ermöglicht schnell und haben
alles reden für giessen.de in dem bin
ich der honig drin profis ich dann schon
einige tipps gehe oder probiert ski und
das gibt sicher da einige tipps von
damals erwarteten familie weil der
schweizer sauber-teams
unternehmensaufbau kam vor allem von
grund auf neu und das ist eine weile
zwei verschiedene viel erfahrung und
ramallah die tipps geben
also quasi ist vorbei und das ist so ein
platz auf place of peace kunststoff es
ist ruhig natur auto gern mit hey du
bist ganz anders machen als im büro
sitzen und sketchen und man wird mit
heimischen jeder honig machen
wasserleitungen in sachen wo man es
normalerweise nicht gut für die seele
gut for the spirit
[Musik]
wie soll ich sagen die ich nicht
kontrollieren und zitterten sie bringen
dass du mich auch mit risiko und das
lernen sich mit der natur
ich hatte am anfang auch sachen gefasst
oder erzwungen und das ist im schloss
gegangen und dann irgendwie einen
schritt zurück und dann realisieren wenn
ich lesen eben in ihrer aussage stress
denn dan dan den puzzleteilen place und
wenn das ist im endeffekt ein besseres
resultat
[Musik]
diese oase inmitten der wüste könnte man
dettl ticino nennen
[Musik]
im moment ist das gut
sie ist ja auch allein hier ihr freund
ist in los angeles
wir leisten uns gesellschaft wir
unterstützen uns gegenseitig es ist gut
dass es diesen ort hier gibt gut für uns
beide ist wie ein bruder für mich durch
all die jahre in denen wir zusammen
gefeiert
wir kennen uns seit 2002 das sind 17
jahre
wir verbringen weihnachten
wir stehen allen tessiner los angeles
nahe sind ihm verbunden
[Musik]
ein kleines paradies ein vorzeige paar
ohne kinder ja mit düsen mit dem
erfinder und jetzt sind mir zwei und
nicht das leben akzeptieren und das
beste draus machen und du darfst
aufreger zum herrgott und das leben ja
nur mehr zwei und den können wir
eigentlich wenn man wenn man will
das finde ich schon wichtig und darum
sind nach der sg öpfingen hoffen wir
ihre bank oder großem abstand dazwischen
das ist für l'oréal steht bereits das
semesterende vor der türe
die letzten monate sind viel zu schnell
vergangen
ich fühle mich hier ein bisschen wie in
den ferien aber ich muss er lernen
ich hätte lust nach mexiko zu fahren mir
reicht's langsam
man hatte mir die unis in den staaten
empfohlen weil es leicht zeigte noten zu
bekommen
alle würden sich ausruhen und stadt
ausflüge machen
so ist es aber nicht zumindest nicht für
ihn erledigt ich habe viel weniger
freizeit als ich dachte ich schlafe
nicht viel und nach den langen tagen
lernen ich noch in der bibliothek nicht
wirklich lustig man merkt dass sie hier
doch sehr besorgt sind um das wohl der
studierenden gestern gab es massagen zum
entspannen sie tun ihr bestes damit
alles möglichst gut abläuft
die dining wohlfühlt wohl weil du immer
mit verschiedenen gruppen ist und dich
zu irgend jemand hinsetzen kannst außer
heute ist alle haben prüfungen
ich habe mein handy vergessen
ich langweile mich ich hätte gern das
menü ohne bohnen
[Musik]
es gibt vier menschen jeder hat eine
andere ausrichtung die hier macht
einfache amerikanische gerichte pizza
burger zwei drei sachen dann gibt es
eine mit asiatischer küche eine macht
auf gesundes essen und eine bietet
europäische gerichte sie sind hier
wirklich recht gut verglichen mit
anderen deinem holz
[Musik]
stimmt es ist recht teuer aber es hat
sich für mich gelohnt
unterm strich bin ich angenehm
überrascht ich hatte befürchtet dass
sich auf die typisch amerikanischen
klischees treffen würde
aber ich finde die leute hier alle sehr
nett vielleicht liegt es auch daran dass
wir in kalifornien sind
man hatte mir gesagt kalifornien sei der
beste bundesstaat voller programms
sondern in der ersten woche hatte ich
noch befürchtet dass die leute zu
oberflächlich sein aber ich habe
überhaupt keine probleme
kommt noch hinzu dass ich richtig glück
hatte mit meinem zimmer kolleginnen die
sind echt nett alles in allem bin ich
sehr zufrieden mit meinem aufenthalt her
[Musik]
das abenteuer hollywood der american
football
ich konnte so viele geschichten erzählen
im tiefsten inneren habe ich mir immer
gesagt dass ich es bereut hätte wenn ich
nicht weg gegangen wäre
[Musik]
es ist gut dass wir beide künstler sind
so können wir uns gegenseitig
unterstützen und sie hilft mir sehr
ich mache musik für sie und zeige ihr
bilder und sie macht dasselbe für mich
sie zeigt mir ihre sachen es ist gut
diese unterstützung zu haben sich gut zu
kennen und zu sehen wie sich ihre arbeit
auch weiterentwickelt sie arbeitet immer
es tut gut diese energie ständig um sich
zu haben
das bin ich kurz bevor ich gern
verlassen habe du erkennst du mich nicht
hier ja da sehe ich ein bisschen aus wie
du mit langen haaren habe ich meine
mutter noch nie gesehen das bin ich okay
jetzt sehe ich es die hausbesetzungen
waren immer auch eine party
da hatte ich schon längere haare und
hier bin ich in meinem atelier malen und
hier bin ich im café hier habe ich sie
sofort erkannt das ist das genfer hotel
da habe ich eine zeit lang gelebt dann
war ich ziemlich frustriert denn auf
einmal gab es eine hierarchie und leute
mit weniger charisma tier aber
vielleicht verrückt erfahren oder die
die sachen weniger politisch sein und
kreativer war auf die wurde weniger
gehört ich gehörte nicht zu den
wortführern es ist super cool zu sehen
dass meine mutter so unabhängig und frei
war als ich jung war
sie folgte ihrer leidenschaft ich finde
das total bewundernswert ich habe das
studium immer als möglichkeit zum reisen
gesehen
deshalb war ich zuerst an der rax
akademien amsterdam und dann an der ucla
in los angeles um einen master of fine
arts zu machen wir verlieren freunde wir
finden neue freunde dass ich die reise
des lebens und das ist super so ich
hoffe ja dass uns alle freunde erhalten
bleiben wenigstens ein bisschen
und sei es nur im herzen
[Musik]
aus den augen aber nicht aus dem sinn
doran pascual verabschieden sich von
ihren freunden
wir schätzen eure jahrelange
freundschaft sehr und du schuld ist mir
noch 20 dollar ihr werdet uns allen
fehlen aber wir werden in der schweiz
sein und ihr alle habt donald trump
[Applaus]
abschiedsessen für don pasquale nur das
heimweh ist nicht eingeladen
leute ruhe bitte das sind die leute die
in unserem haus bund werden
[Applaus]
ein toast auf dora sie werden uns sehr
vielen pascual und dora
ich hatte das glück durch kennenzulernen
als ich ganz unten war ich hätte den job
gewechselt um mein leben ein einziges
chaos
das energie ihr charisma und alles an
ihr haben mich sehr beeindruckt ihre
tanzstunde besuchte ich wegen ihr
sie bringt alle zusammen das ist das in
distanz die ballettstunde vorbei war
wissen sie was sie zu uns sagte raus
jetzt raus mit euch
[Applaus]
das leere tor nicht
wenn die liebe berührt dem auch der
erfolg gebührt
[Musik]
der mond scheint die seelen zu
besänftigen
und die hektik zu mildern
[Musik]
jeder verfolgt seinen traum
jeder lebt sein leben alles eine frage
der haltung
[Musik]
ab
schweizern in los angeles präsentiert
wurde forces stockheim und egal wo sie
sind
[Musik]